that signals the end
of the skt dynasty the upset is complete
as the kills come through
the skt dynasty is over
all hail the new kings samsung galaxy
your 2017 world champions
that was supposed to be faker's lowest
moment
the greatest player of all time in tears
his dynasty shattered because he just
wasn't good enough after that crushing
loss
2018 was supposed to be faker and skt's
comeback year
they were on a search for redemption
trying to earn back the title of the
greatest league of legends team in the
world
instead it was their worst year ever
as kramer picks up the kill now they're
all gonna flood forward there's
knock-ups left right and set up a double
kill
as kramer his only game of the day and
he picks up the double and ends it for
the afrika freaks
it's a 2-1 it's a different story for
the first meeting
skt will have to hope that this week is
an aberration i say that skt
don't have the players to go far over
the course of multiple matters
it's always been winning they're getting
used to this feeling their worst
season ever they reached new lows once
thought impossible for league's most
prestigious team
and their star player once considered
the greatest of all time
was fading but the team's 2018 woes seem
like a faded memory this year
after two lck titles a rift rivals
trophy and the top four finish at worlds
skt are back so how did skt do it
how did a team that hit rock bottom in
2018
turn it all around and make top four at
worlds the next year how did skt get
their groove back
by starting from scratch
so after the loss that brought faker to
tears at the 2017 world championship
skt decided to make some roster changes
huni and peanut were out
and skt needed replacements they lost
worlds
sure but skt still had their legacy
almost any player would jump at the
chance to play with the greatest team
in the world skt could basically pick
whoever they wanted
but instead of signing elite players
like they did in the past
skt instead formed a 10-man roster
primarily made up of new
young talent they hoped that they could
find their next stars with this lineup
instead they found disaster
sk telecom if you look at all the
players that they've had on the roster
since
2015 you look at it and it's like well
it's like [ __ ] pokemon right you have
ash ketchum which is faker and then you
just have this
ragtag group so you got ash ketchum in
mid and then you're giving them [ __ ] all
nothing like let me just read you this
roster
thaw blank faker banging wolf
what a dumpster fire to say this roster
underperformed
would be an understatement it sucked
nexus is under fire but it's the battle
that we're looking at def picks up one
we've got low health bars
and smebs just fighting faker the flash
comes and the minions
are going to be enough and the nexus
falls kt
nine to one dominant early game dominant
mid game
nothing going to their head all the
members of skt have to go running to the
hills maker goes over the soul with
designers hourglass trying to keep
himself alive and in the fight
but he's just too damn low he'll get
spat out goes back to the fountain and
mvp
they have done it they're not 10th place
yet
mvp still occupies that spot but they
are sinking
lower and lower the young players were
underwhelming leaving skt struggling to
form an
even half decent starting five the 2018
season came and went without skt really
never figuring it out
instead they found the team's worst year
ever and now
they're looking for the final push the
moment the nexus towers under siege
griffin
will not be stopped an sk telecom
will be eliminated from the lck summer
playoffs in 2018
the first time in history and during the
loss that knocked them out of playoff
contention
faker sat benched on the sidelines so
heading into 2019
skt weren't exactly the legendary team
that
everyone wanted to sign with instead
people were even wondering if faker
would resign
faker can only indulge that level of
failure for an amount of time he's still
so amazingly driven i think skt was
pretty liberal
with the changes in their roster last
year especially
you know in 2018 after their 2017 second
place they dropped peanut they made
other changes
they tried to invent new stars and
didn't stack a roster with talent were
humbled you know they didn't really find
any success at all
in 2018. skt's response to the doubters
was to do the exact
opposite of what they did the year
before dump their roster and build
a super team khan klid teddy
mata and of course faker
this was the lck dream team khan was a
back-to-back lck champion
[ __ ] with a jungle star in the lpl teddy
was arguably the best 80 carry in korea
and mata well that is one of the
greatest league of legends players of
all time um
um
skt were finally back to being
contenders faker finally had the
reinforcements he needed to take back
his throne as the king of korea
and in january their assault began
skt bulldozed their way through the
spring split the only team they couldn't
beat was griffin and by playoffs
skt found their revenge see your death
and see
your defeat in the lck final for spring
2019
spring often does this to us gentlemen
we often get
the quick ones in the early stages of
the year but this is one that i don't
think
anyone expected skt 3-0
over griffin after their incredible
first round robin give them their moment
to bask in the after goal skt have
destroyed team griffin to register
their spot at the mid-season
invitational and also
after a year of mediocre results skt
were once again back on top and faker
and coma
couldn't help but get emotional
[Applause]
oh dead
yeah this is a very emotional moment
right now a month after their spring win
faker and skt were off to vietnam for
the mid-season invitational
where they met their newest rivals g2
esports are looking at the nexus origin
they're trying to fight back but they
cannot do it
origen are crumbling to g2 europe
kneels to its champion g2 esports
the world awaits g2
like skt g2 were their region's super
team
but unlike skt g2 were wild cards
they played whatever the hell they
wanted they didn't follow the meta
they created it korea didn't have teams
that crazy
which meant that skt just weren't ready
for g2
and it showed a little bit of an
exchange here caps has already used the
perfect execution
goes all the way back in with the flip
five point strike picks up for killing
to mata now yanko's looking for the stun
that's a double kill for caps he flashes
over the wall but here comes cord
charges into him for devastating effect
faker is not done he's got himself a
mega knight
here comes wonder to the wall into the
crunch
the wallet faker gets a reply but it
doesn't matter five men party in the
chicken cap
and skt are running for their lives
captures trying to find the kill
matches in trouble fake as low but
they've already got one of tomato where
is teddy follow his hp bar
khan flashes off the walls and he's dead
yet gus is in the pit g2 esports have
been
gifted and donated a baron
from skt that's a dunk from wonder death
from below
for the double for the ace for the
barons
the gap be damn champions can fall gods
can bleed
where were you when the west rose
up to conquer champions g2 esports
eliminates sk telecom north america
faced europe at
[Music]
so you'd think that skt would go back
home to korea
stronger from the lessons they learned
at msi but that didn't happen
by week three of the summer split skt
were in ninth
place
but in week 4 skt slump ended all thanks
to an
unexpected roster change perhaps what
he's thinking here is that he doesn't
want to give up priority in
mid well there's the abyssal voyage
efforts going to come in with clear
no qss available just yet for ruler and
he is well dead teddy
picks up his third of the game really
really nice play
for the early game on skt side effort
was part of the group of rookies that
skt
signed in 2018 but he was also one of
the ones who survived the culling when
skt built their super team the next year
and then he just rode the bench at least
until it was time for him to save
skt i think effort does a lot of uh shot
calling as well i mean
i think he is very vocal on this squad
effort was
always a pretty practice player right
yeah they were
very good some of the best uh some of
the best skt games in 2018
were because effort was the pike player
the carry of the lane
skt were hot they picked up a trophy at
rift rivals and entered the playoffs
ready to go
but they needed a miracle they had to
win three series in a row
just to get to the grand finals africa
sandbox dam juan and finally
griffin in the grand finals one by one
skt brought every team down in their
quest to
win a second consecutive lck title a
feat they hadn't accomplished since
2015. skt was heading to worlds as
korea's
number one seed but faker had his eyes
on one team
i want to make a revenge on g2 that we
were defeated too
at msi semifinals we had a very close
game but we lost
so i just want to get my revenge on them
as a whole now here's the part of the
video where i love to say that
skt beat g2 and then they went on to win
worlds and everyone lived happily ever
after
but that's not what happened tries to
buy a bit more time here comes making
the backside he's caught up by the olaf
mickey now coming in faker trying to go
and finish it up but the stopwatches are
there but no
skt still able to find this fight the
knock-up coming through
yankos runs for the hills but it is not
enough still it's a back-and-forth fight
it's such a close fight cap manages to
side step
click goes in but the body set comes out
another stopwatch are you kidding me the
knock-up is there
the shutdown is there g2's ability
to out team fight skt has been
persistent
throughout this series they're caught in
the pitch mickey x can go forward faker
invisible wants to pull another grass
play but this is fast to the vladimir
trying to strike back but fake result is
not going to be effective
condo has to run for his life baker
missed his kiana ultimate
in the jungle the back end of that
ultimate faker now steps forward faker
now gets taken out
faker what was that
this is his hero moment if he wants to
turn this fight in favor of team this
could be the game he gets the final
moment
on the list there's no way he can duel
yasuo ahmad is coming in but he's just
walking into the meat grinder of perks
caught can't do it they've done it
can he get it done he can't the vladimir
they can't do it
this is it the greatest team in the
history of league of legends
taken down by the greatest team europe
has ever produced
this g2 esports team was not built to
win
it was built to conquer
the loss was painful for skt they had to
come
so close and let it all slip through
their fingers
skt not winning worlds in 2019 did not
turn the entire year into a failure
despite what reddit might have you think
for skt and
korea as a whole 2019 was all about
rebuilding
for me last year was the failure and and
for me last year was a very real failure
of the lck
this year i would not consider a failure
i think last year
is your doomsayer year last year was the
board clear
this year they rebuilt and then uh
you have the the king returning
basically reforming with different
pieces
yet still keeping some of the old um
and the most important ones you know
with you know faker and stuff like that
sure skt are no longer the undefeatable
titans who win every tournament they
enter
but honestly that was a pretty
unreasonable expectation for them
and this year skt freed themselves of
that
faker is finally able to just play
league of legends
he isn't here to uphold a mythical
dynasty he isn't here to be a living
legend
he's here to win and now he has to work
just as hard as
everyone else faker didn't win worlds he
didn't even make the finals
but he's failed before and he's always
come back hungry
wait what the [ __ ] does that mean there
shorts is not even a title we just call
it that internally it doesn't have a
title
with this is the series with no name
the no name right yeah we're no we're
the no name brand of the score esports
stick me in a yellow tin uh put black
text on me or whatever give me one of
those holler
shirts